I would love to hear do you guys do you
guys like the show of course we do
addicted yeah yeah
that throwback clip of Amy robach
interviewing Reese Witherspoon just went
viral after Amy's secret romance with
her Good Morning America co-anchor TJ
Holmes was made public the water cooler
conversation
[Laughter]
and honestly the drama is giving major
Morning Show Vibes I am so mad at you
there had to have been a million and one
women out there who didn't work on the
morning show I think that you're jealous
because of our history last week The
Daily Mail published pics of Amy and TJ
packing on the PDA all over New York
which got people talking since Amy's
married to Melrose play Star Andrew shoe
I'm doing all right
considering everybody thinks I should be
falling apart and TJ have been married
to Marley fibig and a
tour staff at Jesus
2010 a source previously told ET the
journalists both separated from their
spouses back in August but the two have
been temporarily taken off the morning
Show's third hour as ABC execs figure
out what their next steps will be good
afternoon and welcome everybody to what
you need to know on this Monday Amy
Roebuck and TJ Holmes have the day off
and in light of all that an interview
with Amy talking to morning show star
and Creator Reese Witherspoon in early
October has resurfaced online I would
love to hear do you guys do you guys
like the show of course we do addicted
yeah yeah if you have no idea to water
cooler conversation
I think we already did that you did yes
yep that's Amy telling Rhys she has some
storyline ideas for the hit Apple TV
Plus show I thought it would be kind of
an interesting idea for for Bradley to
be curious and also more open and create
sort of this messiness this mess between
her public and personal life of course
the morning show follows the behind the
scenes drama of a Morning News show a la
Good Morning America but you did not
deny it you didn't say no and now it's
in a book as for TJ and Amy a source
previously told E.T that Kimberly Godwin
the president of ABC News addressed the
situation during a morning editorial
meeting on Monday saying that while the
relationship has become an internal and
external distraction it is not a
violation of company policy and for now
Stephanie Ramos and Gio Benitez are
filling in I'm Stephanie Ramos and I'm
Gio Benitez we are so glad you are here
with us to begin this brand new week
here on gma3 well we'll just have to
wait and see if the morning show draws
inspo from this real life event when it
returns for its third season in 2023
but what we do know is what Rhys told us
about the hit Apple TV plus series when
ET chatted with her back in July it's a
lot of hard work and but it's one of
those shows that really touches people
because I think it's really speaking to
the truth of what it is to be a woman in
the workplace a particular woman in
media so I think it's really resonating
with audiences around the world
[Music]
thank you